[Music]
what do you get when you give two morons
a baseball bat and a frog one of the
most successful and controversial
animated series of all time
this is the untold truth of beavis and
butthead
as a high schooler mike judge loved to
doodle in his notebooks during class but
he eventually pursued a career in
engineering when he happened to attend
an animation festival however he
rediscovered his longtime love of
cartooning he revealed to the av club
i'd always wanted to try animation i
thought of animation as something i
wanted to try if i was ever rich or
retired
judge spent two hundred dollars on a
bolex camera acquired a light box some
ink and paper and drew a cartoon about a
nerdy office worker named milton judge
sold his cartoon office space to the now
non-existent comedy channel for two
thousand dollars and it went on to
inspire the 1999 comedy of the same name
that was when judge realized that making
cartoons could be a full-time job
then we'll be able to get money and
chicks and stuff
yeah yeah
we are there
judge canceled his plan to become a math
teacher and created another animated
short called frog baseball the shorts
starred two deviant youths beavis and
butthead both voiced by judge
violently abusing a small amphibian
mtv's animation showcase liquid
television bought the shorts and network
executives liked it so much that they
signed judge to produce 65 episodes of
beavis and bud hat
not only are beavis and butthead among
the most uniquely unintelligent
characters in tv history they've got two
of the most original names seen on the
small screen
creator mike judge got those monikers
from real life inspirations telling wild
cartoon kingdom
when i was in college a 12 year old kid
next door called himself iron butt his
friend actually we called butthead even
though that wasn't his name then there
was a kid in the neighborhood about
three blocks away his name was bobby
divas
judge says that the real-life beavis was
nothing like the cartoon character he
just liked the name the character's
distinct voices came from real life too
judge explained to the daily bruin that
beavis's high-pitched cackle came from
this guy in my calculus class that would
sit in the front and always bite his lip
and turn back and go hey that to me just
turned into his laugh
as for butthead judge says that the
inspiration for him came from his
childhood having once dealt with
uncomfortable dental problems judge
revealed i had braces in high school and
they'd scrape your cheek and you ended
up talking like butthead that's how i
got the voice for butthead just a guy
talking with a mouthful of wires
not counting a couple of shorts that
aired on liquid television the first
episode of beavis and butthead debuted
on mtv on march 8 1993 to immediate
success network vice president abby
turkel told the los angeles times
they're perfect for mtv they like and
respond to things that our audience
finds humorous maybe our audience can
see a little bit of themselves in beavis
and butthead
mtv knew it had a hit on its hands and
made plans to produce merchandise and
feature the duo elsewhere in its
programming all before its premiere
unfortunately plans took a turn just a
week after its premiere mtv halted the
show's three daily errands with just a
handful of animated segments the network
had to rerun them endlessly during
premiere week because judge and his
animation team had fallen behind instead
of showing the same few episodes for
weeks mtv pulled the show momentarily
and brought it back in may 1993 with
plenty of new material
hey put it
how long until something good's on tv
uh
two hours dude
beavis and butthead watch tv attend high
school and slack off at work in a sleepy
little town called highland its sandy
terrain constant sun and hot
temperatures suggest that highland is
located somewhere in the american
southwest such as new mexico or texas
the ambiguous location of highland was
my judge's intention he said in an
interview at the austin film festival i
grew up mostly in albuquerque and i was
in dallas when i created it so i was
thinking somewhere in between those like
just one of those like a little town
like lubbock or you know mortalis new
mexico
when the 1996 film beavis and butthead
do america went into production an
animator slapped texas license plates on
some cars and background shots judge was
happy to go along with it joking so now
it's texas
half of any beavis and butthead episode
involves the titular characters wreaking
havoc on their school and around the
neighborhood the other half involves the
characters sitting on a filthy couch and
offering savage critiques of music
videos
once in a while beavis and butthead
would come across a band that rocks or
rules and viewers would get a little
animation of the guys head-banging or
dancing
musical artists that received this
exposure and an on-air seal of approval
often experienced major boosts in record
sales
before bevis and butthead debuted in
early 1993 the band white zombie had
sold just 75 thousand copies of its 1992
album la sexorcisto devil music volume
one after the cartoon featured a white
zombie video sales quadrupled and the
album hit the billboard top 40 chart
babes in toyland's little notice 1992 lp
fontanelle started selling about 1 000
copies a week after bruce violet hit
beavis and butthead for a rock band in
the 90s getting your video on the show
was a recipe for musical success
for every band that enjoyed the exposure
they got from beavis and butthead there
was another that took offense when the
show made fun of them in one episode the
boys briefly view an aerosmith clip and
come to the conclusion that the band is
pretty cool even if they're old
according to mike judge aerosmith
pressured mtv into taking it out and
they never watched another aerosmith
video again
on another occasion mtv once told judge
to stop making fun of the hair band
winger because the channel quote had a
good relationship with them even if an
artist liked the show their music could
still get mixed during the brief 2011
beavis and butthead revival kanye west
wanted the duo to watch and riff on one
of his videos judge told rock newsdesk
he wanted it on and then somebody who
owns like six percent of the songwriting
said no
uh
yeah
it makes sense to me
beavis and butthead weren't exactly what
most parents would call good kids they
cat called women they were rude to
adults they listened to loud and
aggressive heavy metal music and they
loved playing with fire bevis in
particular was a pyromaniac and in early
episodes he'd flick a lighter and shout
so often that it was basically a
catchphrase in october 1993 about six
months after beavis and butthead
premiered on mtv a five-year-old ohio
boy named austin messner got a hold of a
lighter and set his bed on fire the
blaze quickly spread throughout his
family's mobile home
messner and his mother darcy burke
escaped but the boy's two-year-old
sister unfortunately died in the fire
burke and local authorities placed the
blame for the tragedy squarely on beavis
and butt head she claimed to have
recently caught her son playing with
matches and removed his bedroom door so
she could keep an eye on him area fire
chief harold zigler told the new york
times when you take a child into
formative years and you get these
cartoon characters saying it's fun to
play with fire this is going to stick in
that kid's mind
mtv spokesperson carol robinson promised
the network would look into the issue
and ultimately ended up removing all
references to fire from past and future
episodes of the show in 2008 massner who
was 20 years old at the time came
forward with his side of the story i
literally never saw the cartoon how
could i it was 1993 my mom was a drug
addict we couldn't afford cable it's
stupid just to blame a tv show for the
problems that a family is having it's
not i mean it's not real anybody knows
that's not real people
beavis and butthead spawned all kinds of
tie-in merchandise including the 1993
geffen records album the beefus and
butthead experience it included a cover
of sonny and cher's 1965 hit i got you
babe as performed by beavis butthead and
the real share in the cover beavis and
butthead explain how the legendary
performer checks all the boxes for what
the duo wants in a woman during a spoken
interlude in the song butthead asks cher
didn't you used to be married to that
bono dude from u2
when she clarifies the situation
explaining she was married to sonny bono
butthead calls her ex-husband a wuss and
cher agrees saying well kinda yeah
the exchange was improvised in the
studio in one take caffeine executive
tony berg told the los angeles times
she was not just a willing participant
but also she got into the
self-deprecation of it and how funny it
was cher's ex-husband didn't find it
funny though sonny bono told the los
angeles times i've got very thick skin
so i would probably lose about one
second of sleep over the whole deal but
in a way i'm sad to see cher reduce
herself to that kind of humor
rightfully considered problematic today
beavis and butthead debuted one of its
silliest and most memorable bits in 1994
bevis's alter ego the great cornholio
whenever he rapidly consumes massive
quantities of coffee or sugar bevis
pulls the neck of his t-shirt over his
head and declares himself the great
cornholio
you can take me but you cannot take my
bone hole
or i have no bunghole
using a quasi-latin american accent
beavis typically causes mayhem as the
great cornholio while demanding toilet
paper from strangers if anyone dares
interact with beavis while he's in
cornholio mode yells out his rhetorical
catchphrase are you threatening me
the character seems like a baffling
collection of nonsense but its origin
comes from a true source mike judge told
phoenix new times
it just hit me like a ton of bricks one
night when i was about to go to sleep
beavis should pull his t-shirt over his
head and start babbling
judge doesn't remember where the name
cornholio originated but can pinpoint
the inspiration for the voice an irate
customer from when he worked as a movie
theater ticket taker he explained i had
to tell people to wait outside and this
one middle eastern guy came up and said
no i will not wait outside and i said i
was sorry but those were the rules and
he said are you threatening me he kept
saying it and it stuck in my mind
when beavis and butthead originally
aired on mtv in the mid-1990s the
channel was primarily an outlet for
music videos the title characters who
were music-loving metalheads fit
seamlessly into the format each animated
episode was broken up with segments of
the duo watching pop and rock videos on
mtv while offering commentary ranging
from unabashed praise to pointed put
downs beavis and butthead creator mike
judge also voiced both beavis and bud
hat and in order to record the video
commentary he employed a particular but
loose process he told wild cartoon
kingdom in 1994 i just go in and
improvise a lot of them a lot of times
one of the writers will come and just
hang out and kind of help out but we
just watched the video a bunch of times
and then i go into the booth and mess
around
segment producer suzy lin would edit
judges bits and jokes merging them with
clips from the music videos and recycled
animation from the show judge revealed
all the cutaways of b and b during the
videos are all pulled from past shows
once in a while we'll animate one
despite being each other's best and only
friends beavis and butthead routinely
cut each other down with crass crude and
demeaning insults most are full of words
we can't say here but there's one that
stuck out for its timber creativity and
reference to something more profane
dilweed plenty of kids and teenagers in
school hallways imitated what they heard
on beavis and butthead lobbing the same
insults at each other unlike the other
phrases however dilweed was actually
created and coined by mike judge himself
it's an adaptation of an insult he'd
used and heard as a kid judge told the
all when i was in junior high in the 70s
people would call each other gweed it
was a pretty common insult i tried to do
it in beavis and butthead and standards
and practices at mtv wouldn't let me say
it
during a recording session he improvised
the word dilweed instead and it stuck
judge elaborated it kind of got a laugh
and it cleared with the network's
sensors so i just kind of kept doing it
after more than 200 episodes the hit
movie beavis and butthead do america and
millions of teens imitating the great
cornholio beavis and butthead ended its
run on mtv in november 1997. the
two-part finale featured a live
thanksgiving special with mtv news
personality kurt loader and a final
animated installment called beavis and
butthead are dead of course phoebus and
butthead don't really die they just
forget to go to school for three weeks
when someone from highland high calls to
talk with a parent beavis claims that he
and butthead are dead to get them off
the phone so why did the show end well
it was time for creator mike judge to
walk away he told the los angeles times
i actually wanted to stop a little
sooner after the second season i thought
how are we going to do this anymore i
was completely burnt out
so by 1997 he wondered why not retire
before it gets too stale or whatever hey
butthead
are we gonna die
[Music]
probably
judge immediately moved on to other
projects such as the second season of
his successful animated fox sitcom king
of the hill
daria morgendorffer a cynical smart
exasperated highland high school
classmate of beavis and butthead didn't
appear in mike judge's original beavis
and butthead cartoon or any of the other
early shorts according to huffpost she
was created after judge sold the show to
mtv in order to flesh out the world of
the series judge's inspiration for the
character was independent cartoonist
linda berry and her semi-autobiographic
comic strips
judge told vulture i partly based the
character daria on how i imagine linda
berry would have been in high school i
drew daria dressed like linda would
dress when she went on letterman
after beavis and butthead became a smash
hit judge and the rest of the writing
staff slowly eased daria out of the show
according to the new york times viewers
expressed their praise to mtv for the
minor character mtv writer glenn eichler
said basically she was the smart person
who hung out with beavis and butthead to
annoy her parents
in 1995 mtv issued a directive to its
collective of writers and producers to
make an animated show with a young
female viewership in mind eichler
suggested to executives that they didn't
need to create anything new they could
simply spin off daria onto her own show
thus daria ran on mtv from 1997 to 2001.
in 2009 mike judge wrote and directed
the comedy extract with jason bateman
starring as a flavor extract plant owner
dealing with a troubled marriage and
problems at work earning middling
reviews and only 10 million dollars at
the american box office extract was a
rare misfire for judge but it did lead
to a brief revival of beavis and
butthead are we dead uh
i guess not
judge told collider that during a
marketing meeting for extract someone
came up with the idea of a promotional
clip featuring beavis and butthead
watching a scene from the movie and
commenting about it on their famous
couch now throw in another relative flop
from judge the short-lived 2009 abc
cartoon the good family and the stars
aligned for a full-scale revival of
beavis and butthead on mtv in 2011. mtv
didn't show many music videos anymore so
the guys had to provide snarky
commentary on mtv reality shows like
jersey shore unfortunately the new
beavis and butt head lasted just one
season it wasn't all bad news for mike
judge in the world of tv though he would
go on to create the hit hbo series
silicon valley in 2014.
in the summer of 2019 beavis and
butthead creator mike judge revealed to
slash film that another movie may be on
the horizon judge said i think it would
have to be something that makes it
relevant today i think i might have
figured out a way to do that indeed it
would seem that he figured it out
paramount the parent company of mtv
announced in 2022 that before the year
was out a new movie featuring the stupid
twosome would hit its streaming service
paramount plus
according to the rap beavis and butthead
do the universe the spiritual successor
to 1996's big screen beavis and butthead
to america was described by paramount as
perhaps the dumbest space movie ever
made beginning in 1998 a judge with a
penchant for creative sentencing orders
beavis and butthead to attend space camp
from there the pair accidentally makes
their way onto the space shuttle then
deep into the cosmos before eventually
falling through a black hole and
returning to earth in the 2020s of
course the movie will also serve as a
launch pad to an entire new season of
the beavis and butthead tv series
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]